you guys won't believe this but it is
almost 2025 and I have never ever
touched an R GPU until now introducing
the cheapest brand new 6 GB GPU on the
market Intel Arc A380 although when I
was purchasing this I didn't pay much
attention to the fact that it is a low
profile card so yeah the installation
into today's test system was a Solid 5
out of 10 on a sketch in a scale anyways
the driver installation was Handel free
and the driver software afterwards gave
me like 50 warnings in a row to enable
resizable bar support or I will miss out
on 20 gajillion FPS in games so yeah I
just did that and now let's see what
this gt730 size GPU can do and the best
way to know what this thing is capable
of is of course 3D marks times spy
although after running the test I
noticed that my score was lower than the
average so I went to the Intel Arc
control app and cranked up the
performance tuning to the Max and it
crashed yep so I bed my way into an ark
A380 overclock guide and realized that
I'm a complete idiot since anything
above 25 causes in stability understand
yep what do you know so with GPU
performance boost on 25 and voltage
offset at 225 MTS we got a
5% performance increase amazing now on
to some games on war zone using 1080p
low settings and X on 85% we got an
average of 60 FPS and I mean 60 for a
€125 GPU I'd like to say it's bad cuz we
got 5700 XTS and 260 supers going for
this price but at the same time it is a
completely new GPU with a warranty I
guess well CS2 ran okay although
definitely bottlenecked by the GPU cuz
this ryzen is capable of at least 200
FPS in the Dead match round Forza was
the first game where I was like damn
finally at least one game where it
genuinely performs although I think here
the Intel driver issues kicked in cuz on
1080p High settings I couldn't use any
msaa otherwise the FPS would just tank
to 30 to 40ish from around 80 which is
just weird and also with FXAA it ran
fine although after loading a couple of
races I think the FXAA just disappeared
cuz the edges started to look rough
again on GTA V I was prepared for the
worst so even before loading the game I
set the settings to lowest and I was
actually hitting the FPS limiter all the
time okay great I thought so I set his
settings to high and got these Benchmark
results the game itself ran okay with
some little slowdowns here and there and
there were only a couple of weird things
I noticed first it was the Shadows but
maybe it's just a tree here I don't know
and another thing was this rabbit Moon
walking on asphalt a bit weird not going
to lie Apex on the lowest settings 1080p
ran good yeah I said it it ran good no
problems didn't experience any problems
and now guys something really sad
happened I couldn't launch
fortnite I tried verifying game files
restarting the PC checking for updates
and stuff but nothing helped ABS in the
chat Wukong wasn't great on 1080p low
with XS on 90 % but when I applied the
recommended settings which were
everything on low and DSR on 50% we got
these Benchmark results which were
honestly really good cuz the game felt
amazing on valerant something that I
have never ever seen before happened so
at first I set a settings to absolutely
lowest and received these numbers which
were honestly amazing so I was like okay
then I set the settings to medium
enabled MSA on x2 and all of the
optional goodies on and boom let less
than half FPS I mean I have never ever
seen a GPU go from 460 to 200 FPS in
just one preset change that this thing
is sure full of surprises Rainbow Six
Siege crashed on the first try to launch
it so I got a bit of a fortnite
flashbacks but you know just like a beat
up 3 Series I gave it some love and it
eventually started and on medium
settings we managed to get these
Benchmark results and overall I'll be
honest with you guys I didn't really
like this GPU using it it just feels a
bit off and I don't know how to show you
this in numbers but the drivers still
need a lot of improvement it feels and
don't get me wrong I really wanted to
like this thing and let all of you know
that there's an actually good budget
option we're sleeping on but the reality
is that Midway through benchmarking I
couldn't stop but think that an RX 58 8
GB which can also be bought brand new
for a similar price just feels way
Superior and Powerful for all the office
PC upgraders and those with 3001 power
supplies I would heavily suggest to
throw in another €60 and get the RTX
3056 GB which would be just like the guy
she told you not to worry about the
performance of that GPU is just way
better than this Arc and in my opinion
at least definitely worth the price
premium and guys quick ERS note drop a
follow on our Instagram we are uploading
stuff there too and chief Bastard out
yes